THE LEFT AND MEDIA PREDICTABLY
CONTINUE TO BLAME GUNS ALL IN AN
ATTEMPT TO LIMIT YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO KEEP AND
TO BEAR ARMS.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE
REACTION, WE HAVE THE HOST OF
MICHELLE MALKIN INVESTIGATES,
MICHELLE MALKIN.
DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA OR AS WELL.
WE TALKED OVER THE YEARS, YOU
WROTE ABOUT -- 3.5 OF THE
POPULATION, 13.5% OF CRIMES,
THAT'S FEDERAL, NOT STATE AND
LOCAL.
WHAT PART OF THIS IS CALIFORNIA,
THE GOVERNOR NOT GETTING?
>> THEY GET IT, BUT THEY DON'T
CARE.
IT'S THAT DEFIANCE, THAT
RECKLESSNESS, THAT SABOTAGE OF
NOT ONLY THE SOVEREIGNTY OF
CALIFORNIA, BUT THE SOVEREIGNTY
OF THIS COUNTRY THAT THEY HAVE
SACRIFICED FOR POLITICAL AND
ELECTORAL GAIN.
THEY'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR
DECADES AND FOR JERRY BROWN TO
CALL JEFF SESSIONS AND
DONALD TRUMP ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THEIR ACTIONS, IF THERE IS NO
BIGGER RADICAL OPEN BORDER CLOWN
CAR WITHIN THE ONE THAT IS
FILLED BY THESE DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS.
JERRY BROWN WHO DO CLEARED THE
STATE A CENTURY STATE WITH HIS
TEN DIFFERENT BILLS THAT
UNDERMINE ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW
THAT PREVENTS EMPLOYERS AND
LANDLORDS AND CITIZENS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM COOPERATING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT STATE IS
SAFE, THEN YOU HAVE -- IN 15
YEARS AGO, YOU INTERVIEWED
SOMEONE AND HE ACKNOWLEDGED HIS
MEMBERSHIP AS ONE OF THE MOST
RADICAL OPEN BORDERS IN AMERICA.
MATCH WHOSE SLOGAN IS THEIR
RACE, EVERYTHING.
FOR PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE RACE,
NOTHING.
NOW HE'S IN THIS POSITION OF
POWER AS WELL AS THE OAKLAND
MAYOR, LIBBY SCHAAF.
SANCTUARY CITIES ARE OUTLAW
CITIES.
SANCTUARY EMERITUS AND GOVERNORS
ARE OUTLAW GOVERNORS.
WE NEED TO DO MORE.
WE NEED TO DO MORE THAN HOLD
THEM CIVILLY LIABLE.
THEY NEED TO BE CRIMINALLY
LIABLE.
THEY NEED TO BE KICKED OFF OF
THEIR PULPIT AND PUT BEHIND
BARS.
SPEAK WHAT WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT DACA, WHICH BY THE WAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS WILLING TO
MAKE A DEAL ON DACA FOR THE
MIGRATION DOMESTIC IMMIGRATION.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THOSE THAT NOT ONLY BROKE OUR
LAWS COME INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, BUT THEN COMMITTED
OTHER CRIMES.
IF YOU AID AND ABET THE SYSTEM
AND GETTING AWAY FROM
AUTHORITIES, THE QUESTION IS
SIMPLE.
ARE YOU THEN RESPONSIBLE FOR
WHATEVER OTHER CRIMES THEY
COMMIT IN THE FUTURE?
>> OF COURSE YOU ARE, WHETHER
YOU ARE A GOVERNOR OR AMERICA
MIGHT YOU TAKE AN OATH OF
OFFICE.
IF YOU ARE IN CONTRADICTION OF
THE CONSTITUTION WHICH GIVES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE SOLE
MANDATE TO DEAL WITH
IMMIGRATION, THEN YOU ARE
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE AND YOU MAY
BE AIDING AND ABETTING FELONS.
IT'S A VERY SIMPLE QUESTION.
THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
BELIEVES THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE
POLITICIANS, THEY ARE ABOVE THE
LAW.
THEY THINK THEY ARE POLITICIANS,
THEREFORE THE U.S. CONSTITUTION
AND FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT APPLY
TO THEM.
>> Sean: HAS GOT TO APPLY TO
THEM.
HERE'S MY EXIT QUESTION FOR BOTH
OF YOU.
SHOULD THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
FOLLOW THROUGH AND ARREST THE
MAYOR OF OAKLAND?
I ASSUME THE MINDS OF THE LEFT,
THAT WILL TURN HER INTO A MARTYR
THAT WILL TURN HER INTO A MARTY
MARTYR.
SPEAK WITH THE PRESIDENT IS
COMMITTED TO RULE OF LAW.
HE'S NOT PREPARED TO SEE THIS
HAPPEN AGAIN BECAUSE WHEN YOU
PROVIDE SANCTUARY, LET'S LOOK AT
WHO YOU'RE PROVIDING IT TO.
YOU'RE PROVIDING IT TO
CRIMINALS.
THE PEOPLE WE HAVE TO PROTECT
OUR AMERICANS.
FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS,
I.C.E., DHS, CBP HAVE BEEN IN
SHACKLES.
THEY'VE BEEN HANDCUFFED.
WE ARE ALLOWING THEM TO DO THEIR
JOBS.
>> Sean: I WISH THESE GUYS
WOULD GO TO THE DRUG WAREHOUSES
THAT I'VE BEEN THROUGH.
I WAS THERE WHEN GANG MEMBERS
WERE ARRESTED.
THAT SAME QUESTION MICHELLE
MALKIN.
SHOULD THEY BE ARRESTED?
>> THEY ABSOLUTELY SHOULD BE.
AS I SAID, WE NEED TO HAVE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS HERE
IN COLORADO.
WE'VE GOT DEFIANT OUTLAW
POLITICIANS RIGHT NOW IN DENVER
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS,
THE POLICE CHIEF REFUSES TO
COOPERATE WITH I.C.E.
THEY NEED TO BE BEHIND BARS.
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE LAWSUITS.